so a womanist for the atlantic wrote
this article that i really like it says
if you want marriage of equals then you
have to date as equals and this
sociologist what she found was that
woman who claimed to be womanists
actually have very regressive views when
it comes to their dating lives and she's
shot none of the women considered
proposing marriage so that was a man's
job they said I know it feels
counterintuitive
I'm a womanist the first set but I like
having the guy to be chivalrous the
quality of the streets gender norms in
the sheets heterosexual women of a
progressive bit often say they want
equal partnerships with men but dating
is a different story entirely
the women I interviewed for a research
project and book expected men to ask for
plan and paid for dates initiate
intercourse confirm the exclusivity of a
relationship and propose marriage after
setting all those precedents these women
they these women then wanted a marriage
in which they would have shared
financial responsibilities housework
childcare relatively equally right
almost none of my interview we saw these
dating practices as a threat to their
women it's credentials or to their
desire for egalitarian marriages but
they were wrong
absolutely I've been having conversation
with a lot of women is yeah yeah yeah
I'm and when I talk to them like yeah
what are you even talking about right
flu yeah you're against everything yeah
but it's different in the big D just
going to this tangent that right there
are a lot of thing like that from the
dating side but for the rest of the
world is something like no you can't
just oh okay but I did expect to hear
progressive views most wanted equal
partnerships where they could share both
financial and family responsibilities
almost everyone I interviewed was quite
vocal of their support for gender
equality and didn't shy away from the
womanís to label however I noticed a
clarity disconnect between the straight
woman's views on marriage and their
thoughts on dating once these women were
married
it was difficult to write the ship so to
speak the same jar of sterile gender
stereotypes that they adopted while
dating played out in their long-term
relationships and yet in a throwback to
earlier era many women I spoke with
enacted strict dating rules it's a deal
breaker if a man doesn't pay for the
date
one woman age 29 told me a 31 year old
said that if a man doesn't pay they just
probably don't like you very much a lot
of men they assumed were looking for
nothing more than a quick hookup so some
of these dating rituals were tests to
see whether the man was truly interested
in a commitment she couldn't believe it
I'm not surprised at all I remember one
day I went I had this huge conversation
with one of my woman his friend and I
was like oh girl it makes no sense I
came back home and I was like yo well I
asked my wife yo Stephanie are you a
woman and she's like no don't forget to
pick up the trash girl sat there shocked
and wrote for the Atlantic and almost
every man at home is like duh yeah we
been knowing that knowing there's some
trust my girl won't do this like nah I'm
not that's not my job I'm cool but of
course people should have equal rights
and being treated equal and stuff like
that but then there's stuff that she's
not gonna do she's not a womanist but
yes the pick and choosing we've been
we've been knowing the process the
pattern it's been going on the way
they've been talking yeah that's what
happened when you're talking when you
ask questions you know the thing that we
know is very reprehensible
if you're a guy like us and you trying
to ask questions and listen as a syst
person you have no voice okay so well
listen Womanism is not about telling
people you have to abandon the old rules
it's about giving people the option to
listen this is what I'll say about this
I've been knowing this my budget is
adjusted for this I know what's expected
when I go on dates
I know it's expected I'll be listen I'll
be with a lot of these woman is Bronx
and let me tell you
behind closed doors they love oppression
yeah I'm shocked they level press it so
much they try to pull it out of me and
I'm like nah don't do that you go you go
like the most messed up stuff that I've
ever had to see in the bedroom has
always been with a woman who has hyper
hyper womanist views yeah of course you
go from a woman that's with a choker to
Daddy
you will not depress me to choke me that
he will quit but it's okay I mean one
doesn't one is not the other one does
not it's not because you want to be you
know you have to fantasies that and it's
controlled fantasies that she wanted me
I get that and I understand that it's
not because well you know in the bedroom
is controlled and I decide to and it's
men and then I get all that that it's
just funny how money changes situation
and it's funny how you guys say you want
men to support your professional goals
and all that stuff when you start a
family but the realities as soon as a
family starts a lot of y'all still
switch it's fine it's just interesting
that everything is men's fault when it
comes to how these gender roles are
enforced but the reality is a lot of
women subscribe to it of their own
volition and and when men actually
encourage y'all to abandon those roles
you're like no no no we're not doing
that
one minute like hey why don't I propose
you guys like I would never that's
disgusting we want to be treated equal
we want to be treated equal all right
Terry that part actually you know how
much I want a lady to pay for my meals
see what you did it again never learn
what what the only thing that's gonna
happen in the dance huh mom from Chicago
Elena California you paid for your meal
Addison listen you can wine and dine me
okay but you better come correct cuz I
ain't dating down by myself I'm just
saying
hey listen you ladies you want to take
me out for dinner let's go let's go I
think my Karma's do cuz I've been taking
out a lot of people out for dinners
ladies you want to start doing some
proposing let's go
my thing needs some ringers my fingy
some ringers my fingers need some rings
[Music]
my ring need some figures by reaming to
bigger oh yeah whatever
no let's go I'm ready to be a
stay-at-home dad who trying to husband
me up huh let's go let's get progressive
2020 new year new you new decade new you
let's go
I walked home I'll do this you two thing
you're me come on come on you know
thought this you know no this is stuff
that's virgin hitting the crab ready
take your order Wow hey let's go check
the roll let's do it let's get rid of
these gender norms I got a bad knee girl
you can do the bed to me let's go come
on man
listen y'all want to open doors for me
let's go let's go I'm ready to be
serviced I want to come home on
Valentine's Day and there's rose petals
everywhere I want that I want
Valentine's Day to roll around I'd like
my girl won't take me out let's go bust
get booted up come on I'm ready
twenty twenty let's do this let's be
progressive girl I want you to change my
tires literally and figuratively come on
girl you know give me a jar I'll pretend
I can't open it boo come on I got a
pickle jar home and I got pickles for
you let's get progressive huh nah roses
don't smell like boom-boom-boom
come on now you're not ready okay okay
well you change your mind you know let's
go I better have no game [ __ ] up in my
DMS ah but I'll take care of you [ __ ]
like nah that's not it's not happening
why not it's all swollen like that you
don't progressive I'm not that
progressive
I'm not switching my sexual orientation
on a dime progressive that's too far for
me matters okay
so I'll have to play this video for
y'all cause we had a good laugh women I
don't know why you're surprised that's
all I'm gonna say until then men preps
your wallets make sure your money's
right because these ladies expect y'all
to break bank money clearly I'm good no
I don't wanna know I'm good you don't
want you don't want the rise of the
women no thank you
we're good we're super good okay she
knows she knows her role I know my
roasting over the road and rules to shut
the footings getting I'm just kidding
come on calm down calm down calm down
what would be a substitute for the word
the substitute for the word yeah females
right activists I guess anything else
something loose here something juicier
how about an Emma Watson
sure I like that so uh no that's kind of
derogatory yeah
I never was juicier I named the Watson
who writes for The Atlantic wrote this
article that I really enjoyed she says
if you want a marriage of equals than
Deena's equals and through her research
and through her conversations with
people who are Emma Watson's aka oh we
can't say that word no here's what she
fundamentalist womanists I like that one
okay so a womanist